good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
several months ago YouTube came to us to
talk about a product they were working
on I should stop here and say that in
general I dislike change like I think
YouTube reached its peak in July of 2007
when our channel looked like this and
the site went down for maintenance
almost every single Wednesday
I enjoy anachronism like physical books
and I guess headphone jacks so I was a
little dubious but I'm genuinely excited
about this change which debuts today but
first let me back up and talk about a
seemingly unrelated thing for the last
couple years I've wanted to make a
youtube show about health and fitness
called 100 days where to ordinary people
spend a hundred days eating well
exercising a lot and doing everything
that's been proven by randomized control
trials to improve your health we'd work
with experts to learn why it's so hard
to make lasting changes in your life and
along the way we would measure our
progress by testing stuff we want to be
better at you know like concentration
tests and push-up contest and hamstring
flexibility which at the moment for me
is just just a little bit limited but
there were two problems with this show
first I didn't want to exercise and eat
well for 100 days because sitting and
pizza aren't just a way of life
they're my way of life and second we
wanted to make this show with lots of
infographics and pictures and recipes
and live shows so it would feel deeply
connected but to do that would mean
maintaining a billion new social media
profiles a thought I just could not
stomach this has been an ongoing problem
because we've always had to build homes
off YouTube for the non-video community
stuff like if you want to submit a photo
or painting to the art assignment you
have to do so via tumblr or Twitter or
Facebook
we can't post worksheets or essays to
accompany crash course videos and to
fully engage with the project for
awesome you have to follow us on social
media YouTube is always thought of
itself as being about video but for many
of us it's mostly been about community
I'd argue that the best YouTube channels
aren't just shows you lean back and
watch their communities you're part of
and for a long time that was seen as
YouTube's great weakness like in the
early days YouTube actually released a
product called lean back that allows you
to watch videos without engaging with
them because advertisers especially back
then thought engaged viewers were bad
news like for one thing engaged viewers
are less likely to watch ads but also
the idea that mass media could be made
and shaped directly by the masses
was kind of terrifying but in spite of
it all YouTube has continued to be a
community platform and today they have
embraced that with the release of the
community tab this allows channels to
post text images live videos and both
gifs and gifts these will show up in
your mobile subscription feeds and on
desktop here in the community section
you can also sign up to get
notifications when we post the community
tab with say a book review or a live
show or results from the nerdfighter
census it's still in beta testing there
are lots of features to come but I'm
really excited about it because one it
means Hank and I can finally make our
YouTube channels to community hubs we've
always wanted them to be two live shows
are now easier and better you can see
this today when I do a live question
Tuesday and three and our beta testing
the quality of discourse in comments in
the community tab has been great like up
votes actually work and also it's much
easier to moderate I just realized it
sounds like I'm being paid to say these
things to be clear I'm not we have never
and will never accept any kind of
corporate sponsorship on vlogbrothers so
we did work closely with YouTube on the
development of the community tab and I
do think it's awesome which brings me
back at last to 100 days so starting
January 1st you'll be able to watch my
best friend Chris and me try to have
like the healthiest midlife crisis ever
the show will include not just videos
but exercise routines recipes live shows
and text posts and it will all live
right here on YouTube a community
platform that also hosts videos Chris
incidentally is known to nerdfighteria
primarily for once appearing in a vlog
brothers video wearing a speedo but
trust me you'll like him so you can head
over to youtube.com slash 100-days and
subscribe now if you want to see me
perform like aerial acrobatics and
hopefully eventually someday touch if
not my toes at least my like mid shins
in a live show later today I'll be
answering your questions about 100 days
and look forward to your ideas about how
to make it awesome Hank I will see you
on Friday actually I will probably see
you before then thanks to the community
tab